peu à peu la vie reprend son cours
c'était un retour en classe aujourd'hui
dans deux écoles ou quatre des victimes
ont travaillé avec nous un des membres
de la famille carrier lourdement
éprouvée frédéric carrier bonsoir à vous
bonjour vous avez perdu votre père yves
carrié votre belle mère gladys
chamberlain votre soeur monde carrier
votre frère charlie un carrier bon la
peine est incommensurable on imagine et
l'incompréhension aussi face à ce qui se
passe
prenons le cas de l'afrique oui
effectivement c'est un choc c'est assez
dur c'est c1 on pense au jour que c'est
de l'irréel on le comprend t on voit une
nouvelle mais on comprend pas que ça
peut nous arriver à nous que le bain on
est pris dans cet engrenage la star iv à
nous ils vous l'avais dit je crois dans
un nouveau témoignage
votre père voulait toujours aller
travailler à les faire le bien et c'est
ce qui nous a frappé tout le week-end et
hier c'est que les membres de votre
famille et leurs amis allaient labo
faire du bien oui ceux donnés y aller je
sais et des juges je savais dès son
prochain déjà qu'ils connaissent pas que
qui dit lorsque lorsqu'ils vont partir
les verront peut-être plus jamais mais
il le sentiment d'avoir fait d'avoir
aidé quelqu'un aider son prochain puis
enfin du bon polar pour la société nos
et avant de quitter
est ce que les questions de sécurité
faisait partie des discussions de fanni
on se disait au burkina faso c'est
plutôt tranquille
c'est presque jamais été un enjeu
c'était la première fois cette fois ci
que quand on était inquiet le revirement
politique à vandaele l'abord puis mais
on dans nos craintes
toute la famille on n'avait pas par un
attentat terroriste on ne va pas on
attend déclaration d'une guerre civile
est pris entre les deux qui prit le
commun qu'on en ressent comme un conte
se débrouille
c'était plus facile et craint qu'on
avait mais on n'aurait jamais on n'avait
jamais passé un attentat terrain de
terreur islamique radicaux surtout quand
on sait que burkin aux impôts notamment
reconnu pour reconnu pour ce soit un
pays est 100% musulman et maintenant
c'est la nouvelle façon de procéder de
l'islamisme radical
c'est d'arriver dans des lieux où il ya
des occidentaux dont le vif dame à paris
on l'a vu dans ce cas-ci en afrique
tirer sur les théâtres les restaurants
et faire le plus mal possible ou plus de
gens de l'extérieur possible
malheureusement oui ça fait mal mais ça
fait partie de ceux qui ont un goût de
farah bien pis si je répète juste des
choses que vous savez déjà vous avez
déjà entendu ils veulent juste nous
empêcher d'aller aider ces gens là pour
prendre le contrôle des pays les plus
fragiles peut gagner du terrain nous
c'est sûr que ça n'a aucune influence
mais en étant debout aujourd'hui en
étant loi vous parlais ma fille livia
qui roulent en est allé faire une course
de ski on essaie juste même si ça prouve
en hormones qui nous arrêterons pour ont
continué hier
votre mère s'est exprimé en dix ans le
canada n'en fait pas assez dans cette
guerre la conduite et henri justement
elle avait honte de son pays disait
telle qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
je voulais pas je veux pas faire de
cette rave entrevue l'enjeu politique
pour ça que je me prononce projet mais
c'est sûr que j'ai mes idées mais il ya
assez de ya eu assez de 2,2
il ya eu assez de gaz a été mis sur le
flanc pour lol ah mais oui effectivement
moi je trouve que le combat doit
continuer puis je voir répéter ce que
j'ai dit un de vos confrères la même
station aujourd'hui le congo il ya
plusieurs heures puis je veux pas qu'on
veut pas qu'on abandonne la portion
militaires les ch'tis a souligné que
l'autre des plus grands aux armes qui
vaut qu'ils peuvent nous aider pour dans
un autre pendant un an dans un avenir
vraiment rapproché mais qu'est ce qui va
faire qu'on pourra vaincre ou réussir à
opérer à affaiblir des organisations
islamistes extrémistes c'est l'éducation
puisque jean lust à tout des professeurs
directeurs d'école ou puisqu'elle est
justement et c'était une des façons
c'était une défense si c'est ce que mon
père avec son groupe faisait c'est
d'éduquer les gens là parce que la
journée ou des illuminés essaie de
mettre des idées dans la tête des jeunes
tous les jeunes sont éduqués il n'y a
pas d'affaires comme nous notre société
a fait envers que ce soit la religion
d'autres héros au tamis notre recherche
est extrémiste exactement il ayant on
voit le bon sens et la morale et non pas
des catholiques ne prend pas des douches
papa de loin la morale devrait être la
même de choc dans chaque religion aux
croyantes donc l'éducation dans ce sens
là est ce que faisait votre père et
votre char et c'est un moyen 1 c'est une
arme qui peut être efficace ou si il n'y
a pas trop mais il n'ya pas que l'iran
exactement mais je dis pas qu'il faut
les arrêter les régler je les condamne
pas je les encourage pour je vous le
prenez ça m'en aller sur ce test mais je
pense que l'éducation est une autre des
plus grosses armes qui va falloir c'est
ce qu'il va falloir que les pays
occidentaux développés faudrait caresche
obligé de vous poser la question on a
dit beaucoup beaucoup de choses depuis
samedi sur la façon dont les
gouvernements le gouvernement canadien a
s'est comporté à gérer la crise et c est
ce que vous personnellement vous êtes
satisfait du travail des communications
que vous avez reçus
a satisfait à 100% non sauf que je veux
préciser que c'est une situation
exceptionnelle que personne ait
nécessairement habitués
je veux pas les condamner je peux les
excuser mais c'est sûr qu'il ya eu
certaines petites lacunes mais je veux
mentionner les médias ont exagéré
certains points
j'ai même entendu asseoir un membre de
famille avait oublié de dire un autre
membre de la famille c'est faux je sais
pas sur quelle sur comment quelques
quelle situation était mal juger mais
moi je suis celui qui a fait le tour de
toutes les membres de ma famille je suis
pro moment - yves richard mon beau-frère
de les premiers qui ont été mis au
courant et j'étais avec fanny ma soeur
mais j'étais avec fanny ma soeur pour
aller voir ma mère puis après ensuite on
était tous ensemble chez g yves richard
il ya pas de membres de la famille qui
oblige la visée par sa cadence de tir de
nom donné aux déclarations qu'on fait
avec la rage parce que là vous entendez
vous savez qu'on reconnaît de la peine
qu'on aura de la peine à corps plein
pendant des années on ne peut pas guérir
de son propos on peut peau saillie sera
jamais fini ce trailer si on a une amie
qui nous a expliqué sur sa grille pas
tout fait juste apprendre à vivre avec
là ça va être la peine le les premiers
jours c'était de la rage souvent mal
compris dans ce qu'on dit puisse citer
la façon que ça fait
qui se porte mieux à la situation pour
faire la sensation et pour le
rapatriement de vos proches parce qu'on
sait que ça peut être un casse tête ça
vous êtes soulagés également oui
l'engagement moi ce que je voulais de
monsieur trudeau de monsieur
premièrement monsieur monsieur couillard
avait déjà manifesté la première journée
même si c'est pas de son ressort il on
va tout faire on va on
on va pousser si on peut s'il faut
composer le gouvernement fédéral on va
le faire mais vous allez avoir de l'ied
fait peu importe ça va être deux ou deux
qui vous allez en avoir
puis est-ce que c'est suite à ce que ma
mère dit je veux pas mais sauf que oui
le gouvernement fédéral a pris
pleinement le contrôle et les rênes du
rapatriement ont fourni les partis qui
nous ont besoin puis ils nous tiennent
informés en attendant frédéric lary
merci beaucoup nous avons parlé vous
savez qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup même
j'étais aux premières loges ya beaucoup
beaucoup de québécois qui ont été
touchés vous l'avez vu dans votre coin
où j'avais dû recevoir aussi plein de
messages alors toutes nos sympathies
pour toute la famille merci nous avons
parlé ce soir merci beaucoup
avec merci